hallo margaret männlich teil auf dieser liste
vs wer hat in der schule entdeckt ich bin lied
nur gefragt
madame mario bruder film ist ziemlich minus d 5 o-140 buddhist jude nun kommt
es darauf an wo ich das erste mal
im radio von nach hause kommen gehört habe  ein
Taxi in Berlin und weißt du, ich
nehme leise mein iPhone und fing an zu
filmen. Ich bin so ein Geek. Ich filme und die
Stadt, durch die wir gefahren sind, und wie mein
Lied im Hintergrund. Ich denke, es
war ein großartiger Moment, es war so ein
Für einen Songwriter ist es eine erstaunliche Sache zu wissen,
dass sich Ihre Musik in das Leben der Menschen einschleicht, wenn Sie im Radio sind,
ob
sie sich dessen bewusst sind oder nicht. Sie werden
zu ihrem Soundtrack. Ich denke, das ist
erstaunlich